c'est simple à de la vodka c'est
dressage josé on nous avons d'aidé on va
jouer tous les deux ont des glaces est
très bien c'est on va en lancer les dés
à chaque fois celui qui fera le plus
petit nombre devra à chaque fois
ce verset de la neige ou dans le dos ou
dans le slip c'est son usage
je sais déjà où je vais le mettre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
fanfare des bars et un tout petit peu
frais y apprend sera pas le plein de
joie quand on était à l'école la
première fois pour février avant ça
m'est resté de vélo création d'un
nouveau toilettes allez-y vous inquiétez
pas ça va de soi attention vous avez dit
oui alors parce que si vous nous
rejoignez dans un instant doha le combat
debout entre valérie bénaïm estelle
denis st japon ça parce que l ce soit un
petit peu chauffé à la radio cet après
midi et ont organisé un combat voilà à
eybens est ce que vous n'avez pas trouvé
votre style
c'est à nous mais bien aux donneurs
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas en culotte
longtemps
ah oui on le fait maintenant il faut
refermer jean savary attendre cinq
minutes faire en espérant que ça ne
marque pas la zone d'effet évidemment
ils vont me regarder la paille typique
forcément très haut le nom la danse
calendar et donne jamais moulage au beau
gosse à lui commandé par une film
aménagé pour des gaules
non
mais y aller
[Applaudissements]
voilà merci bon ces cinq ouvriers c'est
la soupe
voilà ça s'est réglé et elle est revenue
au plateau merci égérie voilà comme ça
ça c'est fait merci merci mes chéris
merci et ben voilà challenge j'espère
que ça va faire mal
abbas avec n'ont pas lâché le plein
parce que quelquefois la neige voisinage
les trois mois la montagne cette fiche
jeu s'appelait dégâts sont compacts donc
non ça va ça a l'air bien ça va bien ça
va faire mal ça va faire maintenant
c'est bien mais tu lâches pas le plat
bah allez c'est parti à l'e3
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]